red is such an intimidating character
one of the most intimidating characters
i think we've seen on tv in a while
you're so good
at just locking eyes with somebody and
you're doing it right
it's terrifying you're doing it right
now you're scaring the [ __ ] out of me
right now
i'm looking at your car
this is fantastic this is my look this
is your look it is it's an arrow
your look is an arrow it can either
liberate or kill
and i'm looking at you in a particular
way why do you think that is i don't
know
unless you don't know
i think that you you implied when you
got here that you have a slight grudge
about something that happened years ago
i'm going to hear about it now for i
honestly don't get that we know each
other very well
not in that way
okay okay how do we know each other well
i know that we've met before i had you
on the show many years ago ten years ago
you almost destroyed my career
i want to know what happened wait a
minute i want to know what he did yeah i
do
in front of millions you forced me to
perform an irish jig that's
absurd
that's absurd that's something i always
respect the guests i've been doing these
this show for 21 years i would never
stoop solo is to make
a character or an actor of your caliber
performance i'm lying no i'm not you're
lying in front of the people
do you have that you have a clip
animal
[Applause]
i think i should get a little slack oh
and i was two
but you know what what goes around comes
around now it's your time to pay
get up and do the dance
let's see if it's
[Applause]
it's not really revenge if that's the
crap i'm doing all the time on this show
anyway
i didn't lower myself to do anything
they had me doing that in the monologue
you elevated yourself i did i just did
elevate myself
uh so uh do you find that you're well
first of all that you all get along so
well clearly that's a cliche i told you
that sorry that's what i heard i don't
know if it's true
but you
why is everyone looking at me
what do you guys hate me no
oh no you because i wouldn't blame you
no you do get along well it's an actor's
response
i get it i guess you all hate me don't
you
all of you hate me
i think we get along so well why is that
because it's vanity free
yes we love you it's pretty vanity-free
oh it is we have to get into those
uniforms you're doing stuff that's
absolutely stripped of ego correct or
not yeah yeah yeah and they're watching
chapel doing it yeah yeah yeah it's true
right because you don't yeah there's
nothing there's nothing other than just
us yeah there's no none of this nonsense
it's very helpful they should have uh
what's vain about conan hosting a show
called conan
[Laughter]
where people all have to chat my name
when i come out
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah this is a real vanity freak
this is fun i mean i this is fun yeah
this is pretty fun i get what you're
saying all right it's a pretty fun place
to be